thanks so much beyond the program you're
very well cook good to have you and so
labor didn't just lose the last election
you had your worst election result since
1935 losing seats that you've never lost
before what do you think went wrong look
it was there's no one thing that went
wrong and in some of the seats that
we've we've never lost before or that
we've held for a hundred years
there is definitely what feels like a
new line in the sand from previous
losses there's no doubt about that
what you heard on the doorstep what you
heard wherever you were in the country
was that basically people didn't trust
the Labor Party on a number of things
but the fundamental was trust so they
didn't trust leadership they didn't
trust our positions on the big issues of
the day in lots of cases they didn't
know what they were and also they just
didn't trust that we could deliver the
things that we were saying it's not so
they didn't like the things that we were
saying it's just that extra bit of the
issue where they could trust us to
deliver is there any bit of the
manifesto that you would have got rid of
then I mean I think that the broadband
as she went down appallingly badly in my
constituency where I found out on the
day that it was announced that how many
Openreach employees I had in my
constituency that I didn't know about
but actually things that fundamentally
are popular with those who have
struggled for them even though waspy
waspy commitment we I have hundreds
thousands of waspy women in my
constituency so the women's pensions
issue I have yeah and we've had a
pressure group and work towards that but
it wasn't that they didn't like it they
just didn't believe it could be
delivered so the manifesto it's not it's
not necessarily that any one thing is
particularly wrong with it it's that
people just didn't believe we could
deliver those things some people are
shrewd people recognize that you you
can't have everything and that things
have to be paid for and things have to
be budgeted for and you said that people
didn't trust in leadership mm-hmm what
do you mean by that okay I think we need
to draw a line and and talk a little bit
more about the future but the reality is
is that on doorsteps wherever you
knocked
doors north-south-east-west the issue of
jeremy corbyn's leadership came up there
isn't there's no point anyone trying to
pretend otherwise and people I think
that people found in the campaign
specifically difficult when they felt
that he wouldn't answer questions and
some of that brand about the principle
was lost in in they're not answering the
questions but yeah you know that people
I don't think saw him as a prime
minister do you think he was a good
leader my criticism of Jeremy Corbyn has
been widely reported I think that he
should that should have been instituted
in the party long way into his
leadership much more listening approach
where all the voices in the party in the
parliamentary level party in the party
membership were were heard a bit more
and weren't just considered as you know
descent in bad faith and disloyalty when
we were speaking up about things that we
didn't like we were doing it because we
could see that there were problems
coming whether that was on the brexit
position from the memberships point of
view or from the position of how we were
handling foreign affairs from the
parliamentary Labour Party's issue I
just I think that a good leader needs to
recognize dissent and be able to listen
to it
another thing that clearly people had an
issue with when him to the Labour Party
Alisha election was bright so it was a
brexit election in many ways and people
didn't like what you had to say now
you've repeatedly argued that we'll be
better off in the EU campaign for a
second referendum new campaign team
who's got lots of people from the remain
side in it including will straw the
director of stronger in I'm going to you
the uber remain candidate of this
contest that's the idea that I'm an uber
remaining I mean I voted to trigger
article 50 because that is what my
constituents voted for but I think that
any politician that doesn't look at the
situation that they have in front of
them about what would be best for the
people that they represent it's best for
everybody in the country and take the
position that they think is right to do
the right thing
I'm certainly not some sort of uber
remain there I don't have like I don't I
don't shred myself in the flag I don't
have a big loud hailer outside
Westminster as a politician I will
always look at what is in front of me
and try and do what is the best thing I
do you say you say it's the best thing
though but lots of people who voted
labor previously voted labour for
generations and didn't at the last
election did not think that staying in
the EU was the right thing they disagree
with you yeah and I think that that's
okay the country we've got into this
position that when people disagree on
individual issues as if you can't then
be trusted on anything else it's a
really dangerous culture where we think
that people people in my constituency a
62% leave vote and the Labour vote in my
constituency fell by the smallest amount
in any leave seat and yet I was clear
with my constituents on my position on
the European Union or how I felt that we
needed to handle what was going on at
the time people are ok if you are clear
and you are honest about what you think
and then they will give you a hearing on
other issues so you know I'm not an uber
remainer
I don't wish feel the need to represent
myself as a neighbor remainer
I am a politician who will do what I
think is right sometimes when that is
hard and I will be honest for the
country about doing that and in my
constituency they are fine with that do
you know what they say to me more than
anything else they say we don't always
agree with you Bob but we know you'll
always tell us what you think and you
know you know we know you're on our side
I'm talking about being honest and open
and telling people what you think if you
were a Labour leader could you ever
campaign to rejoin the EU I don't think
that this is a conversation that is even
open for debate at the moment we are
leave Boris Johnson has a majority of a
tea that has consequences in an election
that was handed to him he now has holds
all of the cards and he can have carte
blanche to do what he wants we are
leaving the European Union and I don't
even think amongst people who voted
remain in the original referendum
that there is any appetite to carry on
having a constitutional conversation
when we should be talking about the
things that people actually talk about
so that there is no plan to have some
sort of campaign to read you in the
European Union but any Prime Minister
who wouldn't look at the merits of every
single Alliance that our country could
have for our safety security peace and
economic viability with a reasoned head
on anyone who closes off their there any
option in the future I just don't
believe that that's an honest position
and people can say it to you they can
sit in an interview and say to you I
will never and I just think politics has
got to be more honest and so you could
potentially very unlikely at this stage
isn't it we're leaving the European
Union and I don't think that there is
any appetite also we've got to make sure
that as we leave the European Union this
isn't about me hoping that it fails I
don't hope that Boris Johnson causes
calamity in the country I don't hope
that I am right about the economic I
hope that the people in my constituency
and all across the country don't lose
their jobs this is about a scrutinizing
what was promised to the people and
making sure that the best thing can
happen in our country this isn't a
political point-scoring point this is
about working to make the best thing
happen and I'm interested as well to
talk about some of the potential
policies that we could see if you are a
labor leader you talked about childcare
this week wanting to make childcare free
from the age of nine months and how much
would that cost
well the conversation what I am saying
about not just childcare but how we need
to be looking after people's families
and how we need to be making an
industrial strategy essentially about
work that actually deals with the
realities as simple as lying how much
would it cost
but the question about how much it will
cost is absolutely something that is
going to have to be worked out over the
next few
years but it's not it's not just saying
oh well what will you cut to do this
what we need to have a really honest
conversation with the public about child
care about social care about the things
that stop families being able to get on
and talking to them about how we're
going to pay for that through different
taxes you should be part of that honest
conversation and look I absolutely
accept your point that free child care
is one of the things that would hugely
benefit the lives of many many people in
this country but you can't say how much
it would cost well surely that's one
things you've got to work out that's
great way isn't it but this is a
leadership this is the leadership
contest we are not going to be in
government for four years what I am
saying is that we need to have a
conversation with the public about the
things that would actually that they
actually talked about and that social
care that is not being able to go back
to work not being able to afford to buy
a house where they live these are all
issues about how people actually live
that politicians very rarely touch upon
the actual lives of actual people and we
have got to have conversations with if
people want services and this is some
one of the problems of where we've gone
wrong in the past people know that
services have to be paid for and we've
got to talk about exactly what services
people need whether they can be
delivered well because one of the
problems with the way that services get
delivered is that we go for the cheapest
path of least resistance and you end up
with old older adults being put to bed
at 5:30 because that's the funding model
that can be afforded we have got to go
out to the country have a conversation
about what they want what they need and
what they are willing to pay for and how
that will be paid for and one of the
other big services of course is
education something that many people
feel really strongly about Labor
conference data to abolish private
schools would you support them look I
worry about some of the messaging and
how that that hit happen because you
know I have a friend who has a daughter
with autism who is in a state-funded
place at a private school and what she
heard when we said that was your your a
body and you shouldn't be doing that so
like judging parents
yeah and I you know every parent's
responsibility is to their own child of
government's responsibility is to every
child I think their private schools
should be treated like businesses not
like charities they should be taxed
accordingly but I think that having an
abolitionist root at this stage it's
going to be in need to be a whole system
change but we should talk about making
sure that every single state school is
some where my kids go to the local state
school and it is an outstanding school
and people desperately want their
children to go there that is the
situation that we have to get into so
that people don't feel that they can buy
advantage and buy privilege there is so
many things wrong with the private
school system there and and how unfair
the advantage it gives I mean just look
where I work how many there's certainly
not been any Prime Minister's they went
to the schools I went to all the schools
my kids went to but how many is it for
me - I think we're up to 30 and one of
the other things that all want to ask
you about is drugs and you think wide
open in the past about taking drugs yeah
would you like to see drugs
decriminalized you know what I'm open to
this conversation and I track I changed
my mind and I'm going to be a politician
who admits when I change my mind on this
when I was young there I definitely
thought of course we should
decriminalize drugs but actually when I
became a local councillor and a member
of parliament
I saw the level of effect that
antisocial behavior has on communities
when and feeling that you can't do
anything about it and and I feel quite
hard line about how currently drugs
policy and currently the way that drugs
are not fought against at all actually
if you call the police
for somebody dealing drugs in the house
next door to you the likelihood that
anything will happen it is very little
and people want to see hard action
however in funny enough during the Tory
contest when everybody started talking
about a take of which drugs I think that
a more honest conversation about how
we're losing the war on drugs started
and I am definitely open to different
models there
and decriminalization but I'm not here
saying that you know all drugs should be
free everything you should be able to
buy it in every shop I think but I think
we do need to have a conversation
because what we're doing now is
currently not working no fewer people
are taking drugs people drug deaths are
rising risk is rising and crime as being
wildly affected by it now just talking a
bit more about your campaign labor
clearly needs to you know find a way of
uniting the party form you know people
on the Left people in center ground
people who have fallen against brexit
people in cities and towns some would
argue that you're quite a divisive
candidate and you told Diane Abbott to f
off you resigned from jeremy corbyn's
and in his PPS in 2016 saying to jeremy
corbyn i'm worried you can't see that
you've made this all about you are you
really the person to unite people look
you know i feel that some of the way
that we talk about the Labour Party is
not at all my experience of it at all
going around constituency labor parties
all over the country for the last four
years I think that we have to be very
careful that we don't believe what you
see online and there are people who
don't like me in the labour party just
as much as there are people who don't
like Jeremy Corbyn in the labour party
but everybody in the labour party
fundamentally has the same values I
don't recognise I am from any faction in
the labour party these things these
labels have often been given to me so a
bit unfair you think sometimes that's
life there's politics people people will
pigeonhole you for all sorts of
different reasons whether it's your sex
your your class your where you come from
whether you come from a town or a city
most people in the country want the same
things and I think that we put these
terrible dividing lines in but my
experience of the Labour Party is that
they agree with me on most things
whether that's welfare whether that's
families rights whether that's LGBTQ
rights women's rights I don't see the
divergence that's constantly presented
to me and we've got
one man yeah in the Labour leadership
content yeah is that the first time
that's like what happened how do you
think it would look if the Labour Party
ended up electing another man true to
form it has a blind spot in this regard
it always has and it is just it's
genuinely frustrating because the Labour
Party is absolutely if you set the test
as being how it is improve the life of
women in the country how it has fought
for women's representation how it fights
for women in politics at almost every
level except that one and so I think it
it does a disservice to it the Labour
Party's record on women but I think it
would look bad if I was obvious yeah in
April when we met and last year you told
me it would be a massive embarrassment
if a party once again fails to have a
woman leader I think that I fairly
pretty much especially when there's one
man in the race of four women
so you think could be a bit embarrassing
yeah I think it will be missing and
what's more it gives absolute grist to
the mill and ammunition to our other
side I've had you know Tory members of
parliament like laughing at us after the
last time especially when Theresa May
because if they were had an all-women
shortlisted and because it was Theresa
May and Andrea let's you know it's it's
not great if we can't ever seem to think
that the women are good enough it's
always some when you're a woman in
politics you're always the next time
it'll be your turn next time when you're
a woman in politics it's always like
you're always tell we're we have to pick
the best person for the job as if that
best person what they never mean the
best person they often mean the best man
and that is disappointing do you think
men need to step aside sometimes I think
that if you truly believe in women's
representation sometimes and that that
goes not just for just women in the way
that intersects in other areas that
sometimes passing the mic is the
greatest way to show
that you truly believe in something but
I think it's a very very difficult
argument to say you should stand back if
you truly believe you're the best person
for the job
Jess Phillips thank you very nice